it's some the thing that's been
interesting even though development
platform is not really fully announced
and released the the world of startups
has been sort of discovering it and lots
of people are realizing that there are
ideas that they may have had in the past
which just couldn't realistically be
implemented which they can now actually
implement and build companies from and
so on and there's a whole stream of
startups it's actually the it started as
a trickle and is now becoming more of a
gusher of startups contacting us to say
that their that they're going to build
their their their companies on our
technology stack which is which is
really nice to see and that's happening
through our development platform system
now one of the questions when you say
start off with a small piece of code
that you write in Morton language and
then deploy it you know will the scale
up a few if you end up having a website
where you put it up and a million people
come to it the first day you put it up
will it will it actually work well this
year we ran a couple of tests of what
will actually happen so we had a purple
a couple of things like for example this
year was a pi day of the century you
know 3 14 15 date and so we put up a
website that was actually extremely
trivial it's a tiny piece of wolfman
language code and this is a website
where it computes you know where your
birthday occurs and the digit sequence
of Pi and you can generate a t-shirt
with the with the requisite to stuff on
it um and this was some this is a it's a
it's a very small piece of code and it's
probably this is just a blog i wrote
about it but Tim um the see whether
where the the code is pretty much here
um and most of the code is involved with
making the graphics and and and and
setting that up but in any case so we
put this this out on pi day and a
million people visited it in the first
day and the site worked fine in the
particular case because was our very
first
we had some issues with logging some of
the things that were happening on the
site but then a couple months later we
put up our image identify website that i
showed earlier and again million people
visited the first day and it worked
perfectly even though it's actually
doing a much more sophisticated
computation so this gives us being able
to do these kinds of tests is important
because it means that people who build
their companies based on development
platform can expect that if a million
people come to their site the first day
it's actually going to work so that's so
actually we can we could take um what's
that yes that's right that's right this
is American Pie day only what's that no
we haven't done a European pi day we
were considering there was also a towel
day on 628 we did an analysis that we
looked at all papers on the archive
preprint server to try and analyze when
pi occurs does it usually occur as 2 pi
or not and actually pi is the winner
it's two pi is not it's it's not the
case that pyas comes combined with the
two it might be but you know it's
something you can get by analyzing all
of that all of that textual data in case
the the so okay let's talk about some so
so with development platform you get to
deploy things in a lot of different ways
you can deploy not only to the web but
also to mobile under we have the Wolfram
cloud app which is a free app that
allows you to deploy which allows you to
access notebooks you can do a whole
Wolfram language computation if you want
to and see I'm going to route time here
side but let me just see go let's go to
the cloud and let's go here oops can you
see the top of that maybe I can go and I
can say create new notebook and now on
my iPad here come on wake up
um I can be saying make a new cell with
language input and now if I want to I
can go you know compute whatever I want
to compute 1 2 3 4 factorial and now
this is running there's running against
the cloud but this is now running
directly inside my M this this is now
running the interface in the iPad you
can also deploy forms and so on to the
iPad you can deploy them you can even to
my surprise you can even do often
language programming perfectly well on a
phone which is kind of neat you can also
deploy these things two things like the
Apple watch and like when the Apple
watch came out I I spent a day writing a
bunch of apps for the Apple watch a
little bit stunted because there's a the
input is kind of difficult on on a wash
but there are plenty of plenty of
interesting apps that are just purely
sort of situational that that current
can run on a watch well when you talk
about deploying things the the we have
our public cloud which is kind of the
the way that the open cloud is set up
and sort of the first place you deploy
to with development platform the other
thing that we have that's now and we
have a limited release of and it will be
coming out as a sort of full release
soon is our private cloud and we were
able to take all of the sort of cloud
technology that we have and package it
up to deliver a virtualized private
cloud that can either be run inside
generic infrastructure like Amazon or
can be run an on-premise solution or can
be run in actual hardware that we
provide private cloud turns out to be
it's both of great practical use to
people who have large kind of corporate
deployments that they want to do it's
also relevant if you're worrying about
HIPAA compliance and various kinds of
confidential data kinds of things there
are so many practical reasons for using
private clouds for example one of them
is if you have a big piece of code
that you're running API is against you
want that piece of code to be you want
the kernels that are running it to
always be pre-warmed so if the thing if
you're loading in a gigabyte of data to
be able to do those computations you you
you if you were doing that on the public
cloud you will be sharing the the nodes
with lots of other users and your
gigabyte would not be loaded in until
somebody actually requests an API but if
you have a private cloud you can pre
provision all of those kernels so that
they can instantly run with with your
gigabyte of of initial data other kinds
of things you can do in private clouds
you can do things like access external
programs and private clouds that we
won't let you do in the public cloud the
you where you can actually access you
know pieces of Rossi code and so on the
other thing you do in a private cloud is
run a continuous task so for example if
you noticed our tweeter program website
where we're where you send a tweet to
Twitter handle and we'll compute the the
tweet is a piece of Wolfram language
code that's less 140 characters long
it's remarkable how much you can get
done in 140 characters of wealth and
language code you send the tweet and
it's picked up by a server which then
does the computation and sends back a
picture of the result that's an example
of a continuous task running in a in a
private cloud and that's the type of
thing that you can do is just run
continually in a private cloud doing
things like that so so another so among
the ways to deploy system there's
deploying in the public cloud that's
deploying a private cloud that's
deploying it for mobile you can make in
under iOS you can you can deploy into
the hour wolfen cloud app on Android
you'll be able to deploy directly into a
standalone app that can access our cloud
the I might also mention something which
is coming after a very long time is CDF
player for iOS being able to have local
CDF run
completely on on on and on an iOS device
that's been a that that's another you
know basically we we used to many many
years ago we had different front ends
for Mathematica for different platforms
windows there you know X Windows Mac and
so on and then sometime in the 90s all
of those different front ends got merged
into a nice elegant software stack now
we're back to the past again because
there's now completely separate user
interfaces that have to be provided for
the web running through JavaScript and
through browsers and running under under
iOS and on mobile platforms the the
world of front ends has fragmented again
and so we have ended up building these
large software stacks that service each
of these different types of interfaces
probably at some point in the future
we'll be able to merge these again but
what typically happens in these
situations is that the capabilities of
these individual user interface
environments aren't great enough to let
you do anything good without having
really native code and in those
particular environments and so we have
to build that native code so any case
the the so another sort of deployment
channel is some the through CDF native
CDF undone on mobile devices so another
another deployment channel is through
for example the shell so for example
you've always been able to say since
1988 you've been able to you know go to
just go to a shell and start typing
things in and that all still works and
it's useful that it works because a lot
of the a lot of kinds of environments
now for iota Internet of Things devices
and so on this is important something
that's coming soon is the thing where
you can just type all from dash cloud
dash code and then we can say something
like I don't know 100 factorial or
something and what this will do is it
will run it's been authenticated this
the script has been authenticated here
and now it will simply run against
against the cloud it will run the piece
of code 100 factoria
um and so can you edit in a shell no you
can't edit that can you um I don't even
know how to do this this is a okay so um
you know you can you can go ahead and
you can go ahead and do whatever you
want to do but but what's what's
relevant here is that you can basically
write a shell script that will access
our cloud and if you have an API that's
deployed in the cloud you can access
that that API function directly from a
command line shell script that you can
put into another program now you can
also take this and by removing the word
cloud there we can actually run this
locally against a local kernel running
on this machine we can set it up in a
variety of different ways we can either
have a pure local kernel running on this
machine we can have a a server that's
running on our local network that's
serving that's providing wolfman engine
for a bunch of different machines or we
can go to a private cloud or we can go
to the public cloud and the point is
that these are all kind of transparent
types of things to do you just change
some option and you're going to a
different place the so just to talk
about if you write a piece of often
language code you deploy it in the cloud
you you can deploy it in these different
places one of the things that's coming
is a Wolfram engine that is an
embeddable Wolfram engine or you can
take that code and you can simply have a
Wolfram engine that runs a dynamic
library connected to your existing
program in whatever language you're
using and then you can with the exact
same interface you can call you can call
the engine when you need to to do often
language computation okay so this is so
this is some of the things that are
coming with development platform one of
the other thing I had mentioned in them
on the front page here is programming
lab completely different direction so
development platform has to do with
people creating production code and
production systems and starting
companies and those kinds of things
another great
is that we have opportunity that we have
is to teach computational thinking and
programming to people I think we have
now a unique moment to try to do that
because with Wolfram language we've got
a language where a lot of the sort of
all of the all of the grunge work has
been automated and we've got to the
point where we can really be talking
about computational concepts and doing
real-world kinds of computations very
quickly and this kind of gets one to the
question of sort of how does one teach
programming how should one teach
programming with welcome language what
would the world be like if everyone
could program interesting interesting
questions and programming people still
think when we talk about programming
they think about either writing scratch
code or writing JavaScript code neither
of which both of which I think will
remain and probably increasingly be be
well scratch different issue but but
with JavaScript code and so on these
will be specialized activities just like
people they will be the assembly code of
the future people don't write assembly
code anymore because there are
higher-level languages these kinds of
things will be the assembly code of the
future and what will one will always be
the what's important about Wolfram
language is that we're trying to take
things to the point where you are as
precisely as possible describing what
you want to do you're not telling the
computer how it should do its work
you're simply describing what you want
to do and then it's up to us to figure
out the automation to get the computer
to do what you want and that's that's a
form of communication that I think is a
is a is is the sort of surviving an
important form of communication I mean I
view it as being at a very global level
I view it as kind of being a this idea
of knowledge-based language is sort of a
the next step in the progression of
which human natural language was kind of
the previous step it's something where
we're now able with human natural
language it's a great form of
communication but it has the feature
that you know when when one person talks
to another the the the the receiving
brain still has to process has to absorb
the natural language it isn't something
where it can immediately execute and
what is described in natural language
that's sort of process herbs
ocean that has to be gone through with
with a computer language one is able to
sort of directly communicate and
immediately execute and what is
communicated and that's something that I
think is going to turn out to be a
really pretty profoundly important thing
that's that's that's happening now and
you know with Wolfram language we for
the first time got a language which can
actually talk meaningfully about things
in the world not just about sort of
abstract moving data from register to
register but about actual practical
objects in the real world and so on any
case one of the things that's neat is
that in a sense the the kids don't have
any disadvantage relative to sort of the
world's sophisticated rd folk in
understanding how to program in in this
kind of knowledge based language and so
I think there's a great opportunity
right now to teach the the coming
generation so to speak how to think in
computational terms and how to program
with Wolfram language so the next
question is how to actually do this how
do you actually try and teach whorfin
language well we have a thing we call
from programming lab which will be
available both in the cloud and and on
the desktop and it has two basic
branches one is what one might call
immersion language learning and one is
kind of more structured language
learning so sort of in the immersion
language learning mode here's a piece of
code that works modified in some ways
see what happens if you really want to
you can read the details of how the
thing works you keep going here you try
to understand more you try to go through
and go further and so on this is this is
set up to be a way of just exploring the
language where were you're just starting
from examples and and and trying to and
trying to get interesting things to
happen well the another approach is sort
of a more structured approach to
learning language I mean the immersion
approach one one learns human natural
languages you know immersion is you go
to country
and you don't talk English anymore and
you try and understand what's happening
in the in the native language an
alternative approach is more the way
that people you know learnt Latin and
things like this where where you have a
more structured kind of textbook type
approach and one of the things that Tim
so one of the questions then is you know
something like mathematics has had you
know a thousand years to figure out the
sequence in which one can teach things
for computational thinking and
programming education with you know the
kinds of capabilities the Wolfram
language we're basically at you know T
equals zero for that term for figuring
out how to do these kinds of things so
we have to figure out everything from
scratch so I thought this was an
interesting challenge and so and
actually I've been sort of hoping that
some some other folk would write kind of
introduction to well from language books
and things like that but it hasn't
happened I myself was off books for a
long time because as many of you may
know I I spent a decade writing one
particular very thick book which got
finished in 2002 and that kind of put me
off books for for a while because a
decade is a is a long time to to be
doing a project but I decided about
three months ago I decided okay there
really needs to be a sort of elementary
Wolfram language book and so I've sat
down and I wrote one and it's it's
almost finished and that's the this it
looks finished but this is just it'll
it'll go to the printers in a week or so
this is it'll be available in sort of
all possible formats free online and so
on in fact this site is now live and you
can take a look at the preliminary
version of it the it's sort of
interesting that tongue you know the
kinds of things that I don't know
there's a pretty early section seven is
about colors and styles and it guys you
know there's a question of in what
sequence do you teach Wolfram language
and by this point one's got enough
information that one can see you know
how to do you know blending colors and
making tables of colors and so on and
then there are exercises I myself have
never really done exercises in any book
ever in my life but I tried to write
these exercises and I I'm really
interested in feedback that people have
about about these exercises the some of
them are interesting things happen
the exercises I think come the what's
what you know the sort of sequence of
what one gets to talk about in Morton
language is sort of not perhaps what you
would expect for programming education
for example you're going through here
and you're doing you know graphs and
networks and you've got all kinds of all
kinds of interesting graphs coming out
and so on and you've got all sorts of
things about I don't know you know
functional programming and nest lists
and all this kind of thing and all this
happens and is some is it's being talked
about by the way I should say that this
book is a completely non math book it
doesn't mention algebra it mentions
algebra in the section on things we
haven't discussed at the end of the book
and so for example it doesn't mention
plot it mentions list plot by about
section 2 but it doesn't mention plot
and it's it considers taking a power of
a number to be sort of a somewhat
sophisticated operation but nevertheless
it gets pretty deep into things like
functional programming and so on and
interestingly i realized that assigning
names to things that is setting values
for variables occurs in section 38 of
the book and before you ever get to
assigning values to variables you've
deployed websites and created mobile
apps and all kinds of things like this
which is sort of interesting in view of
the kind of the what people
traditionally think of is what
programming is about you know I was
looking because it happens to be about
to be ADA Lovelace's 200th anniversary
or something I was looking at the very
first program written by the Lovelace
actually I don't understand line for
appears to be wrong so I'm kind of stuck
there but that program was the thing
that was moving moving data around two
registers those were registers that were
hope to be made in the analytical engine
made of you know brass and so on but
basically a lot of what people are
teaching and programming education is
extremely similar to what was in the
original Ada Lovelace program moving
data around from register register this
is not what computation is about the and
you know I think what we get the
opportunity to do is to kind of define
what what computation really is about
and how to think about things in cavite
tional terms and I've tried to make sort
of one pass how to do that in this
particular book I might mention that the
template for creating this book we now
have a pretty good template in notebooks
for creating this book and we'll make
this template available and this this
book is this book should not be the only
book of its kind and there are you know
for example there's a there's there's
many obvious books that for example do
mention math for instance that that need
to be written well okay quickly going
through some other things that we have
on the way also on the way in terms of
general platforms is our data science
platform that's really emphasizing the
idea of going from a data source through
analysis to generating reports and we
have very flexible ways of both
ingesting data from a lot of different
sources and generating different kinds
of reports data science platform
probably will be out end of this year
beginning of next year I think well let
me talk about other kinds of technology
we've been working on quickly here so a
lot of stuff to do with connected
devices you know we started a couple of
a year and a half ago our connected
devices project just inventory all the
different weird kinds of connected
devices that that exists something that
came out this year is more from data
drop this is a very useful thing the
idea of it is it's a a universal
accumulator of data from things and buy
things I mean well there's a Web API
this you can send things at Twitter you
can have embedded code you can send
thing from Arduino 'he's you can send
things from all sorts of different
little embeddable devices the idea is
that you can just throw data into the
data drop from anywhere so for example
within our own company whenever we put
up a form we're throwing data from that
form into data drop and the point is
that what what happens is when you've
thrown data in today to drop within
Wolfram language you get a data bin and
so for example I could look up what data
bins I have okay here a bunch of data
bins I have so let's say I don't know if
his is a thing from sensors a little
sensor that I have on my
desk so we can say something like date
list plot of that data bin and now this
will retrieve the data from that data
bin from the cloud and then in this case
because I'm running on the desktop here
it'll now go and and show me hopefully
some date list lots of data from from
that particular data bin I don't know
why it's taking so long to retrieve it's
usually faster than this um but oh there
we go okay so this was you know humidity
pressure whatever temperature these are
a bunch of time series I can now just
pick up these time series and manipulate
them directly using Wolfram language
functionality this is a super convenient
thing because it just allows you to to
connect sort of real-world objects and
put their data directly into into the
language and there's a notion of a data
signature where we're using our natural
language understanding stack to be able
to take in data and interpret things in
terms of what units it's in or if it's a
geolocation or if it's a date or
something like this okay another thing
that's coming is data repository we've
been talking about this for a couple of
years but it's finally going to be
arriving soon the idea of this is that
we will be able to have resource objects
which are kind of universal lumps of
data that will exist globally in our
cloud and we'll be able to you'll be
able to send things to the data
repository and then they will be able to
be available either to everybody
publicly or to set specified collections
of users it's it's leveraging our kind
of general cloud infrastructure to
provide a way to distribute different
kinds of data to people another thing
that's coming is what I've been calling
compute back links so when you deploy
something for example let's say you take
a piece of graphics let's say we just
take a random piece of graphics like
this and we say cloud deploy that lets
cloud deploy this thing then it'll just
show up as a web page it'll show up as
something on a web page you can embed
that thing from your web page that's
hopefully how it's it's a live object I
think um this particular thing as some
kind of light object okay there we go
anyway so you can embed this on a web
page and what will happen is that you
will have
you'll be able to automatically get it
to include a source link so that anybody
who sees that on a webpage that say it's
in a scientific article or something
like this will be able to click the
source link go back to the notebook that
created that particular graphic and then
potentially if the raw data that
underlay that graphic is in the data
repository go back from the source
notebook to a resource object in the
data repository and go find the raw data
and be able to do their own computations
from it so to me this is an interesting
it's sort of data backed publication I
think it's it's the it has to be the way
of the future it's been supposed to be
the way of the future for a long time
but they really haven't been streamlined
tools to make it possible I think we now
have that with our cloud particularly
with some of the open cloud initiatives
that we have and so on it will be very
easy for people to add these kind of
compute backlinks these source links to
be able to show people where did that
picture in that article come from and
let them work with the data that it came
from well okay lots of lots of things
happening in other parts of our world
system model oh there's new version of
system modeler we're doing a lot of work
to integrate system model into whorfin
language so that and we will be working
on just as we've been curating things
from numerical properties of things to
images to other kinds of things will
also be curating types of devices and
specifications of devices so that one
will be able to run these simulations
with in Wolfram language and offer them
in system model a' okay other things
that are coming another area that will
be coming is so pub/sub technology
notion of channel brokers and channel
framework so one of the issues is if
you've got a Wolfram language kernel and
you want it to talk to somebody else's
well from language Colonel interactively
you want to you want to have a chat
session with them how do you do that
well you will be able to do that using a
thing we call the channel framework
you'll be able to open a channel publish
a channel be able to give an ID for a
channel and then the person at the other
end can make a receiver for that channel
which for example if they trust the the
source of the channel they'll be able to
just X
code that comes across that channel so
you can you can then set up it's it's
rather trivial to set up a you know a
chat session that's exchanging Wolfram
language code and so on and there are
many other uses for this pub/sub
technology was the way we're doing it is
really kind of an industry standard way
of doing it so that you can communicate
not only with other Wolfram language
engines but also with other programs out
in the world through this kind of
two-way communication channel and we
will be we will support an efficient
channel broker in our cloud
infrastructure other things coming a
thing called cloud store which is kind
of a way to have databases that a very
lightweight and efficient way to have
databases operating in our cloud another
thing that's happening is get linked so
internally we we use the get versioning
and source control system we built out a
lot of technology for managing
interactions with get within Wolfram
language that will be being productized
over the next six months or so and will
be important for people who are doing
large-scale development projects in more
from language being able to sort of
symbolic being able to analyze all sorts
of commits and all kinds of things like
this another thing that's coming is a
lightweight local web server not
relevant for production but highly
relevant for development where you can
actually from within you have a Wolfram
engine kernel and you're you're directly
specifying functions and you're able to
immediately run them in a web server
that that is on your machine another
thing that's coming is marketplace so
when people build forms api's other
pieces of code we will have a
streamlined marketplace essentially app
store where people can can get these
things both for free and with payment
we're generally working to sort of
integrate with everything so for
instance I don't know here's a here's an
integration maybe I can show it to you
this is a this is an integration with
Google Docs so here we can go ahead and
say open a wolf mouf a sidebar here okay
so we've got some kind of
let's say we say some random thing here
we can do a computation hopefully come
on wake up and there we go and we can
just take that picture and drag it over
here no we can't well so much for that
um that's very weird i don't know what
happened there um it should have just
appeared in the in the hmm well i don't
know how to use google docs so that okay
so that you can also do things like if
you want to let's say we say a thousand
factorial here you can say up here you
can say send that too often language and
this should be able to just run that
computation using essentially a google
docs document as a front end for the
system you can also do the same thing in
in the google spreadsheet perhaps you'll
be able to do the same kind of thing in
excel type spreadsheets and so on that's
another thing that's happening another
kind of connector a very different part
of the world is to scratch scratch is
educational programming language that
there's very simple things there will be
things called Wolfram blocks and scratch
where you can make a a block that
executes a piece of wolfman language
code that will be available through the
the scratch marketplace another kind of
connection that's coming is to 3d
printing we've been doing a lot of work
in computational geometry and that will
come to fruition in the ability to be
able to work out what is printable given
a piece of 3d geometry is it printable
in a particular piece of technology and
then being able to automatically connect
to various printing services to do it
another thing that we have done quite a
bit of work on with but we're still
exploring is using things like the Unity
game engine as a front-end to orphan
language where you can have definitions
in more from language and have them
essentially rendered through something
like a game engine another area we've
been doing lots of work on external
services
so being able to link external services
whether it's archive the archive
database of preprints or whether it's
Yelp or whether it's you know google
calendar or something being able to link
these things into Wolfram language I'm
really we have sort of two levels of
integration one is what we call
connected services where you know you're
using somebody elses API and you're but
you're doing computations with it let's
say to open library or something like
this and other thing is what we call
integrated services where you're where
you're actually am where you're doing a
computation where the ok way will you do
for example a web search and this is
using an external API but the results
are just coming directly back into Orton
language so i can do you know something
like a web image search sort of a useful
thing this is not yet available this
will be available soon I don't know I
could do a web image search of ostrich
for example and I could get let's go
ahead and get out of that lets get the
the thumbnails of that I'm for um we
should get a collection of ostrich
pictures okay there we go and just for
fun we can let's let's get those let's
say we just just for fun let's try see
what happens if I just say image
identify all those pictures so anyway
this is running okay so interesting
sometimes it's a sometimes it gives
something more specific sometimes it
comes to that something that's specific
I wonder whether they're actually
pictures of ostriches it was just the
web so we gets hard to know but no case
this is so this is an example of an
integrated service where you just type
web image search and we go deal with the
sort of transaction with the API this
will get billed to your cloud account if
it's using an external API that costs
something other kinds of things of that
kind there's a send message there's a
message sending API which allows you to
send text messages and so on directly
from within the language it's another
example okay other things they're coming
Colonel connection manager this has to
do with being able to start from a
single wolf imagine being able to start
a whole array of other Wolfram engines
that's relevant for our
performance computing capabilities and
also for dealing with Internet of Things
devices where you'll be able to say
remote execute evaluate across a whole
bunch of machines some particular thing
let's say you could remote evaluate
current image and get back a list of
pictures that have been captured from
lots of little devices out in the world
the the thing that we're doing with them
we're trying to build out an HP see
product where you'll be able to take a
computation that you're doing in Wolfram
language and run it in the cloud
probably the initial product will allow
up to 128 cause at a time maybe we will
go to 1024 cause and that will spin up
essentially immediately you'll be able
to just do a computation that's in a
desktop or in the cloud and immediately
say run this in parallel across 128
cause and it will just immediately
happen and that's that's that's
something that's coming I've been
waiting to be able to sort of do instant
parallel computation forever I think
we're finally going to be able to have
it so to the other end of the spectrum
from so the supercomputer world is
embedded computation as many of you may
know Wolfram language has been bundled
on the raspberry pi computer for the
last couple of years and we are working
towards some a bunch of other kinds of
embedded solutions in particular we are
considering building a kind of a custom
Wolfram box that's actually a tiny
computer that boots directly in Wolfram
language where often languages the shell
the computer and one of the things that
that allows us to do is to standardize
the sensor package on the system so that
we can so that we just know this thing
that just booted up has these sensors on
it in particular we're interested in
working on sensor fusion where we have a
small number of broad spectrum sensors
and we've been trying to develop kind of
the network of their about 10,000 kinds
of things you can measure we know that
because we've enumerated all of them for
from alpha and for our unit system and
Wolfram language and the question is of
those 10,000 kinds of things you can
measure how many of them can be deduced
if you have camera data you have some
chemical data you have sound data and so
on can you deduce
different kinds of measurements from
these kind of set of primitive
broad-spectrum measurements so that's
kind of an adventure that's a
combination of physics and machine
learning to try and deduce lots of
different things from a small number of
primitive measurements that's something
that we hope to be able to build into
this wolf in box system that's a sort of
a different direction another thing I
might mention ap is so you can create
your own custom API in Wolfram language
extremely easily you just cloud deploy
an API function as I mentioned you can
also do local deployments etcetera
etcetera etcetera we're going to have a
whole portfolio of our own ap is one of
them is built in function ap is so that
will be thousands of AP is that are
basically convenient ways to access
individual Wolfram language functions so
you know you want matrix eigenvalues you
want to make some plot those are if
those are individual Wolfram language
functions they'll just be an API that
lets you call that individual of
language function in a convenient way
and those api's will be available both
as web api's things like shell api's api
is available from like spreadsheets
things like this and also AP is that are
available from language libraries so
that there'll be just essentially a
language library in a language like Java
Script or something that allows you to
directly call the eigenvalues function
in Wolfram language one way to call the
eigenvalues function will be calling out
to our cloud another way to call that
eigen values function if you have it is
to use a local war from engine if you if
you have one of those set up on your
machine so that's another type of API
that we're planning of what we're
currently calling dead simple api's
which are AP is that are specific for
specific functionality like for example
doing image identification we're
basically it's a very minimal API where
you just you feed it an image it does
its thing it tells you a string back
that gives you the result that turns out
to be something that a lot of people
want from us and we're going to
standardize a kind of a family of dead
simple api's for doing that okay in
terms of our own core development
efforts one of the big emphasis right
now is on speed and compilation and
deploy ability of compiled systems
and we've made quite a bit of progress
on that there's a lot of things that
when you write big chunks of often
language code lots of things are very
efficient right now but lots more things
will become dramatically more efficient
as this compilation technology comes in
a sort of general trend for us is moving
functionality that we built kind of
prototypes of and wolf's mouth or
wolfram alpha is a much less demanding
environment the more from language and
Wolfram Alpha you're basically you're
typing some question and some report is
generated but you only just have to see
that report once in Wolfram language you
can take whatever the result was you
grind it forever and so the kind of the
standards are much higher for what has
to happen so a lot of things that we
were able to sort of prototype whether
it's you know atomic spectra or
something in wolf's mouth does fine if
you're just looking at a picture on the
screen but by the time you're grinding
it in great detail you have to hold it
to a higher standard we've been doing a
lot of work kind of moving functionality
from the almost prototype phase of wolf
now it's still very usable to the the
fully integrated Wolfram language mode
other kinds of things I mean we were
just there's a lot of stuff that is
being like here's a new function in in
version 10.3 host lookup that's looking
at by P addresses lots of systems level
stuff that we need one of the things
that we've been doing as a company is to
try and move all of our internal systems
on to Wolfram language into open
language including all of the things
that we use for monitoring all of our
internal systems all of our ERP systems
all these kinds of things in too often
language and this is a great way for us
to drive development of lots of kinds of
aspects of language as well as to
generate lots of interesting new sort of
spin-off products well another direction
might mention we started a while ago is
to try and take pure mathematics and to
try and take with in Mathematica we've I
think been very successful at sort of
automating a lot of Applied Mathematics
we're also now interested in doing the
same kind of thing for pure mathematics
and so the question is how do we how do
we describe
the world of a pure mathematics in in
our kind of terms so this is an example
of something we're doing along those
lines this is now a type of entity a
function space and so you've got these
very abstract kinds of function spaces i
don't know let's pick one of these some
let's take something popular let's take
one of these lebesgue spaces let's take
that one for instance let's say this and
let's ask for property so this will now
give some properties of this space and
we can start to see places where there's
you know integration over a measure
space and so on these are kinds of pure
mathematical concepts the the idea is to
try and take those pure mathematical
concepts and cost them into Wolfram
language form I think it's going to take
probably to cover sort of all the
reasonable areas of pure mathematics is
probably going to take another thousand
built-in functions and it's going to
take all kinds of design and so on we've
been sort of working with various parts
of the of the world mathematics
community on this thing which we're
calling the math heritage project to try
to sort of take all the knowledge that's
in the three million published theorems
of mathematics and try to put it in
computable form we actually have a
workshop that we're organizing sometime
early next year to to start trying to go
through this process of doing this sort
of the the standardized language design
for mathematics to be able to encode all
that knowledge in that way so other
kinds of things we're doing a lot more
emphasis on machine learning and AI
we've been building up capabilities in
that area something is coming soon is
some in addition to image identify image
cases which means show me all find out
all the cats in this image where are
they those kinds of things we have some
efficient algorithms for that now that's
something very useful in practice
another thing image identifies about
nouns here's an object in this picture
we're also interested in adjectives and
verbs here is a a you know green cat you
know catching a ball or something
this is being able to understand how to
describe sort of real-world situations
in a kind of symbolic way this is a set
of upcoming challenge I've been working
quite a bit on i think it's it's sort of
interesting because the lot of work
that's been done on this was done in
like the 1600s and not a lot has been
done since then of trying to in that
time there was a sort of idea of
developing philosophical languages which
would be sort of symbolic descriptions
of the world we're back to trying to do
that again but now we can actually when
we do it we can actually implement it
well been doing lots of product
development also the our Wolfram
solutions business unit that does
services and consulting and so on has
been growing and doing a lot of very
interesting things doing a lot of work
for particularly large companies and
there'll be a bunch of deployments of
our stuff in sort of very
consumer-facing places over the next six
months or a year that have been built by
our solutions group on the education
side let's see we've been doing all
kinds of things we've been many of you
may know we've had a a summer school
that we've been running for about 14
years now which and we've been that has
been see I had a picture I had a picture
but it was in its in a Tumblr site and
for some bizarre reason tumblr seems to
be let's take a look see what it's
working now tumblr is losing all of its
CSS this morning for reasons that I have
no idea about so much for using some so
much for saving time by using an
external service to them to do something
okay and in case theam see what i can
get here maybe i've got a picture so
this is yeah okay so um this was just uh
what is this that was summer camp let's
see santam
maybe this is just um yeah it's just
this is just some sample projects from
our summer school this year and it's
sort of interesting we had about 70
students this year from around the world
and sort of everybody gets to do a
unique project typically ultimately and
the project concept ends up be getting
developed by me but the result was as a
lot of interesting projects which serve
as as interesting prototypes for other
things that we're doing so one of the
things we're trying to do so we have a
summer school which is a sort of general
undergraduates graduate students a few
other kinds of people we also have a
summer camp for high school students
that also has been very successful and
that we're kind of planning to franchise
out to other locations and so on the one
of the things that we've been doing also
we've been developing a kind of
mentorship program for high school
students college students and others
people working with R&D folk within our
company on projects that we think are
interesting that they think are
interesting too this is a website that
may exist soon which is kind of a
summary of a bunch of projects that
we're interested in that so far mostly
have been invented by me but but the
these are all things which we care about
and we'd we'd we'd like to see somebody
help us with and so we have a program of
working with with students on these
kinds of projects which I think has been
would you just been getting started the
last few months another another thing
that there are lots of kinds of
educational things going on another
venue that sort of interesting is live
coding there's so we've been using this
live coding TV platform for just the
often language is sort of a great
language to just do live coding in
because things actually happen every
minute or so in when you're doing
Wolfram language computations and so
that's that sort of becoming
thing as a as a version that some kind
of combination of entertainment and
education well okay lots of lots of
stuff here um I think I just want to say
quickly and I'm probably really way over
time where's Danielle Danielle usually
is um so well the thing that's coming in
the very near future is the eyes are
open cloud that will start to exist in a
few weeks as I said the thing we're
particularly excited about there is sort
of opening up programming and
development in the way that we've tried
to open up computational knowledge with
orphan alpha but in a sense we are just
providing the platform and what we need
to do now is to show people how to use
our technology stack in lots of
different areas and this is where kind
of the community which means in part you
guys and so on come in so a question is
you know what kinds of things can people
do well one thing you do is start a
company if you haven't already done so
the there are lots of opportunities
building on our technology stack there
there will be a period of time that will
last a few years when there's a lot of
easy stuff to be done that now is
possible that we're not going to do
because our company's focus is on
building tools not on building specific
and deliverable kinds of things you can
also just build an app or build a
website put things in our marketplace
put things in the data repository you
know tell people what you're doing our
community wolfram community has been
continuing to grow and prosper um the
the thing that term is it some we go um
the UM we also things like doing
sessions about what can be done with
with Wolfram language and so on it at
conferences and specialized areas giving
workshops in those kinds of settings
those are those are really good things
to do we've been there been an
increasing number of meetup
groups that have been starting up around
bull from language in different places
around the world we have kind of a kit
for helping people to start meetup
groups we have a collection of student
ambassadors at various universities
we're interested in recruiting more of
those and in having professors and
suchlike work with those student
ambassadors also there are Wolfram
language seems to be becoming a very
popular thing for hackathons a bunch of
people have one hackathons recently look
at that all these so these are recent
notable wins okay that's great from
using both and language technology and
so another thing that people who are
more experienced can do is to be a
mentor for for hackathons the another
thing I should mention is there is a
there is there are an increasing number
of companies that are looking for
Wolfram language programmers and
something that we've been we're trying
to have an area on the community for
this also well our own company is
expanding but there are plenty of
different geographies sort of types of
companies industries and so on where
there is an increasing demand for
Wolfram language programmers and we're
trying to figure out how best to set up
the right kind of marketplace for from
language programmers our human resources
group is actually going to be doing work
with outside people as well trying to
help connect companies that want Wolfram
language programmers with people who
know well from language programming and
want to work for those companies I think
there's some right now for example I
know of a bunch of very interesting
opportunities both with startup
companies and with established and large
companies who are trying to build
Wolfram technology based systems and
need Wolfram language programmers and
our our HR group as they say is well
goes both going to be doing sort of
publicly visible things in the community
and confidential kinds of things for for
people interested in those kinds of
opportunities I just want to mention
again in terms of things people can do
you know write a book you know books I
thought books maybe might be completely
obsolete but the great thing about a
book is
there's sort of a certain finiteness to
what's there and people kind of know
what to expect if you say it's a book
about this they know it's a certain
certain volume of information and a
certain kind of of contained way of
presenting it we are going to be
publishing a bunch of books we have a
publishing operation more from media
which published well the long ago
published Mathematica book new kind of
science mathematical journal etc more
recently published a book their hands on
guide to Mathematica just came out like
a month ago written by a group of people
in our sales organization that's that's
doing really well the basic deal will be
we're not we're more interested in
getting the content of these books out
than we are in for example making money
from publishing books and so our our
thing is we'll will help people who are
where we're we're interested in the
topic and we sort of except the original
proposal for the book will help people
to develop the book then we will put out
a sort of free web version of the book
and then the printed book the e-book the
licensed versions of the book and so on
will split fifty-fifty the proceeds of
that with with the author of the book
and we would like to see books about a
huge diversity of different kinds of
subjects including very specialized
kinds of things and I have to say that
writing this book I don't know what
people will think of this book but this
book was very easy to write I'm having
written a book that was very difficult
to write a dozen years ago this book the
core of this book took basically three
weeks to write and you know it helped
that i knew what i was talking about
least i thought i knew it was talking
about the big problem with the previous
book because i had to do all the
research as well and every time I ran
into like for example writing the
exercises has taken me longer than
practically anything else here because I
don't know anything about writing
exercises but in any case it's you know
writing a book about a thing you know
about with Wolfram language is I think
something with with the tools that we
have it's going to be rather easy and I
think it's going to be be very rewarding
we also i had we've been developing a
course authoring system which
I was going to produce a course with
about two years ago and it didn't happen
but we're going to make this course
authoring a tool available generally to
people other kinds of things i'm almost
at the end here I mean there's just a
lot of other kinds of things out there
you know very simple things that would
be helpful to our to the world actually
is taking Wolfram language and Wolfram
Alpha and open cloud kinds of things and
linking them to things like Wikipedia we
haven't done a lot of that it's just not
something that as a company we've put
that much effort into but there's just
there's we know there's tens of
thousands of pages in Wikipedia that
should be pointing to things in Wolfram
Alpha should be pointing to things in
demonstrations project should be pointed
to things in the open part of either way
the demonstrations project will soon be
be operating purely in the cloud um
other kinds of things people can can
help with I mentioned code captions if
you know a language that isn't in the 15
that have already been that we already
have code captions translated for we
will be delighted to give you the
material to translate wolfen language
function names into into your language
companies we're kind of interested in
just as we're interested in mentoring
individual students were interested in
mentoring companies too we've gotten
involved in a whole bunch of different
companies that are doing things based on
our technology stack we want to have
kind of a more organized operation that
tries to help launch companies and
that's a that's a different topic to
talk about well I should I should wrap
up and this this is as I say we've been
we've been numb it's exciting for me
that that all these different things are
happening right now all these things
that we've worked towards for a really
long time are coming together and
they're sort of vast new areas for us
and vast new classes of users that are
getting opened up and I have to say our
company even though it's nearly 30 years
old continues to as everybody's keeps on
reminding me continues to feel very much
like a start-up and its operation
because we're we're doing all this new
stuff all the time
um and anyway I hope that I hope that as
I said I think there are just some great
opportunities at this point for our
community and for taking the things that
a lot of people have put lots of effort
into over the course of many years and
really making them much more broadly
accessible and I hope you guys will be
able to be involved in that and thank
you very much and I'm sorry I went so
long